Notice so far that Exokernel supports no extractions. It
only has mechanisms for securely giving resources to the Library Operating
System. And the resources may be a space resource, memory, time resource,
or specific hardware resource like area of the graphic display, and
so on. Therefore, exokernel needs a way of
revoking or reclaiming resources that have been allocated
to a library operating system. Of course, exokernel keeps
the scoreboard as to what resources have been allocated
to different library operating systems. And therefore, at any
point of time, it can revoke the resources that
had been given to a library operating system. Sort
of similar to a student working in my lab,
if he or she graduates, I might say, well,
it's time for you to return the key to the lab, and I have a way of revoking
that resource that I may have given to a student for use in my lab. Similarly,
exokernel has mechanisms for revoking resources from a
library operating system. So specifically, for instance, if you
think about the CPU, exokernel has no idea what
the library operating system is using the CPU for.
As opposed to SPIN for instance, which
has an abstraction of strand that represents
the user level that represents the library's
notion of a thread. So exokernel has a
revoke mechanism for exactly this purpose of
revoking resources that have been allocated to a
library operating system. And the revoke call,
which is an up call into the library
operating system, is going to give this library
operating system a repossession vector, saying these are the
resources I'm taking away from you. For instance, it
could say, you know, remember I gave you these
page frames? Well, I'm going to reclaim those page
frames. And when it gives those repossession vector to
the library operating system, it is a responsibility of
the library operating system to do what it needs
to do in order to clean up. In
other words, the library takes corrective action commensurate with
the repossession vector that has been presented by exokernel
to it. For example, if the exokernel tells this
library that I'm going to take away page frame
number 20 and page frame number 25 from you,
then the library operating system will say, oh, in
that case I have to stash away the contents
of those page frames into the disk.
So that's the corrective action that the library
operating system will have to take when it
is informed by exokernel that some hardware resources
that have been given to it have been taken away by exokernel. To make the life
of the library operating system easier, exokernel also
allows a library to seed it with autosave
options for resources that exokernel wants to
revoke. So, in other words, if exokernel decides
to revoke, let's say, some page frames
from the library operating system, the library could
have seeded the exokernel ahead of time.
That, any time you want to take away these
page frames, dump it into the disk.
And that kind of seeding allows the exokernel
to do the work on behalf of the library
operating system. So that, at the point of revocation, the
amount of work that the library has to do, in
order to do corrective action for the repossession, is minimal.